le coronavirus semble ne pas toucher
tout le monde de la même façon quel est
son mode de transmission
il faut un contact étroit avec une
personne malade même lieu de vie
discussions à moins d'un mètre
voyage dans un espace confiné autant de
situations à risque
c'est une transmission aérienne par les
gouttelettes les micro gouttelettes de
salive
notamment lorsqu'on touche lorsqu'on
éternue lorsqu'on crache lorsque voilà
comme comme pour tous les virus
respiratoires
il faut éviter de toucher des surfaces
contaminées et de se frotter les yeux la
bouche le nez des traces du virus ont
été retrouvés dans les selles de
certains patients une transmission par
voie fécale serait possible selon les
scientifiques qui sont les plus exposés
aux coronavirus les personnes âgées sont
les premières victimes problèmes
respiratoires ou cardiovasculaires
diabète les maladies chroniques
fragilise le système immunitaire et
personne n'était galles face aux
coronavirus c'est une publication fait
par les collègues chinoise y montre il
ya peut-être plus d'hommes à table que
des fins et très curieusement sur les
patients qui sont ici ou à bordeaux par
exemple c'est plutôt les hommes qui ont
présenté une forme grave les femmes en
présenter des formes moins graves
les enfants sont pour l'instant moins
affectés que les adultes
quel est le traitement le temps
d'incubation du virus serait de 2 à 12
jours en france
les malades sont placés à l'isolément en
chambre étanche mais il n'existe aucun
traitement
on teste sur les plus atteintes des
médicaments utilisés pour combattre
d'autres virus
les chercheurs se sont rendu compte que
certains traitements utilisés par
exemple pour l'infection vih le sida
était potentiellement également efficace
dans l'infection à coronavirus
les chercheurs de l'institut pasteur
espère mettre au point un vaccin d'ici
un an et demi